false start hi guys welcome to friary
this is the video vlog that is the look
back at all the things I did this week a
lot of stuff happened this week this is
a very busy week so let's get right to
it
excuse me gross here's something that
happened I friary
we're here Ricky Dillon is here hanging
out mamrie Hart is here bringing up
Chester's here and goose is somewhere
just like farting constantly I'm
stealing my cat onesie who's being a
bunch of adults on a Saturday night it
really is what's happening and it's
spicy then this happened
hi guys it is Monday and today is
another weird day in Los Angeles because
I just got done shooting a video with
Larry King and it was absolutely
fantastic I've been shooting videos with
some late-night talk-show hosts to get
some advice for the upcoming a show and
Larry gave me just some real gold
nuggets of advice I feel like a better
person because of it I am really excited
for you guys to see that video it'll be
out soon and now I have a day to get
done so let's get you stuff I can't
forget about this still wearing my
makeup from last night
I'm wearing a vest it's almost noon
happy Tuesday
whoa hey guys it is Tuesday night been a
long day shot podcast with Shane and
she's filming - yeah we're vlogging now
oh this is the worst of people I know I
hate that we have to do it ready yeah
Shane is here we just filmed the podcast
and this is our end result which yeah
very adult much mature I don't know if
that yeah there we go said matures yeah
it's perfect and just got back from
recording a podcast with Chris Hardwick
which was so great we recorded his
podcast and my podcast and then shot an
on the video it was a lot and I really
appreciate him taking the time now it's
Tuesday night watching some housewives
eating some soups and hummus and gonna
edit my video for tomorrow feel him good
and tired then this next thing happened
yeah we're doing every day old hair yes
good morning
it ain't it's Wednesday morning is 10:00
a.m. and we are headed to a fitting for
a photoshoot that we are doing for Eve
tomorrow
the fitting is right now it's actually a
really fun day we're going through this
fitting don't know what Jake's panic
just gonna put clothes on the person and
then we are going to do two more
podcasts Kevin Pereira is the first one
I'm actually gonna be on his podcast and
he's gonna be a mine which will be fun
because I haven't talked to Kevin in a
long time Kevin used to host attack of
the show
I used to do some stuff for attack of
the show and so but then after that
Nikki limo is coming over to my place to
record a podcast with me and do of my
taint I have to see I ordered a shock
ball from Amazon so that she and I could
potentially do the shock ball challenge
makes me really anxious but I don't know
if it has actually gotten delivered yet
let's go have a day
choose juice juice now live on the
Internet forever
jackets here we're about to record the
podcast with Kevin we just recorded a
Kevin's podcast it was really fun and
now we're doing something real dumb yeah
go team here's like a podcast I'm a
podcast on your podcast oh okay then
this happened
we're on set right now shooting photos
everyone's thrilled we're like halfway
through the shoot and look at this
business professional I'll sell you the
hippest real estate the shoot is over it
was really fun it was photos excuse me
promo photos and some promo video stuff
for E and the makeup artist is that
she's great I was she like over drew my
lips and they look a little bigger which
I guess is sexier more feeling but I
feel a little bit like Miranda sings
right now but everyone is really nice
and the guy that did my hair he owns
three French bulldogs so like dreams
come true guys then another thing
happened you get it good morning friary
it is actually Friday and it is 9:20
a.m. right now and I
a huge day also this is the weirdest
thing I'm stuck in traffic clearly and
there's all these UPS trucks around me
right now there's literally the one all
the way behind me you can't see it but
then there's four of them in front of me
can you see those no there's five of
them and they've all been just weaving
in and out of each other in traffic is
this something that you PS chuck's do to
get through traffic is that they all
like keep going in front of each other
and give each other Skype it's very
weird anyway we're headed to meet with
some people okay and then I'm gonna go
shoot a video with joel mchale yeah then
I have another meeting and then a drinks
meeting so this will get edited at some
point in the meantime I'm gonna watch
this dance of the Sugar Plum UPS trucks
I am so confused but also kind of
entertained that's how you guys must
feel watching these videos of mine
don't my majors getting she amped for my
next meeting that's happening
okay guys quick anecdote in my book
there's a story about how in fourth
grade we were studying Native Americans
and we had to make something that was a
traditional Native American item whether
it was like clothing word art or
whatever it was and my dad helped me
make mine ie my dad made mine I made a
Papoose which is essentially a Native
American baby bjorn
over Christmas time when I saw my
parents they told me that they found the
Papoose in their storage unit and so
they just sent it to me and I'm opening
it now
because I told them at Christmas send it
to me I want to hang it on my wall in
like a nice cute shadow box or something
I don't know I'd see it first of all
second of all there's a bow and arrow
and you I guess make me a Peppa's wasn't
enough but I also had to make a bow and
arrow I mean my dad also had to make a
bow and arrow oh my god oh my god it's
delicate fourth grade project
oh it's called a cradle board he's a
baby we'll go in here I clearly did not
make this on my own so thank you - Chris
says these videos aren't goddamn
educational they go guys that was my
week I hope that that was interesting
and any and always if you liked it don't
forget to like this video click the
thumbs up that's really fun because it
makes me feel validated also subscribe
to this channel have a great weekend
I don't know also I forgot while I was
editing this video that to tell you I'm
in a music video mm-hmm and I'm rapping
and sort of dancing for a truth Orange
a truth Orange they're the anti-smoking
company fifth harmony isn't it that kg
is in it king batch is in it Harley from
Epic Meal Time is in it Timothy
DeLaGhetto is in an alpha cat is in this
Jimmy tat wrote a Trojan me I met you on
set and you were extremely nice and I'm
sorry if I'm not pronouncing your name
correctly and a Cana who else I met on
set in this awesome
human it's called left swipe that it's a
video all about how there's been studies
that you are less likely on dating
websites to get connected to someone if
you have a picture of yourself smoking a
cigarette so it's all about left swiping
the people that smoke cigarettes because
it's gross and honestly it does look
stupid in photos it's so stupid and not
the good stoop but not the stupid I like
its airing during the Grammys which is
insane so we want to try and get it
trending during the Grammys hashtag left
swipe debt so make sure that you check
it out and you hashtag I'll be watching
because I love watching myself wrapped
one of my favorite hobbies so the link
for the videos down below or it's on my
face somewhere click it check it out
it's fun